my name is doug krieger i work at github
i manage the semantic code team
our team's remit
is to find interesting bits of academic
research in particular program analysis
research
and to try to find ways to incorporate
those into interesting product features
at github
and so today i'm going to talk about
some work that we've been doing over the
past couple of years to bring a more
precise version of code navigation to
github.com
and the work that i'm going to describe
today builds very much on this framework
called scope graphs which was developed
by elko visser's research group
at tu delft so if you want to learn more
about the
academic work that this is all based on
i encourage you to check out the product
website the project website
and also professor visser did speak
about scope graphs four years ago at
curion barcelona so if you want to learn
more you can also go look at his talk
there it's recorded on youtube
and i definitely encourage you to check
it out
um
so i mentioned that we're sort of
working towards code navigation so just
very briefly i want to make sure that
we're all on the same page about what
that means what that involves is as far
as a product feature
so here we have an example python
program i'm going to be showing a lot of
example programs throughout this talk
most of them will be in python but the
expectation is not that you're a python
expert i'm not trying to do anything
deep with the semantics of python in
particular i just had to choose a
language for the examples and this is a
good one
and so here we have a very simple file
there's three functions defined in it
we have a reference at the end of the
file this is
building on the fact that a lot of the
things that our programs build upon are
names we have entities that we're
creating in our programs and we have to
give them names so that in other parts
of our program we can refer back to
those things here it happens to be
functions but we also have local
variables classes modules all sorts of
things that we might need to talk about
in our programs
and we typically use names to do so
so what i've done here is i've
highlighted in red a definition that's
where we're using a name to create this
new entity in this case a function later
in the file as i said there's this blue
highlighted name
it's still broil this is a reference and
what we're trying to do here is
detect and encode the fact that that
reference refers back
to the definition in question so if you
were to execute this python file when
you get to that last line we see this
name broil the python interpreter is
going to go look for the thing named
broyle see that it's a function see that
it's that particular function and then
go through and execute its function body
so code navigation consists of a number
of different interesting features
the ones you're probably most familiar
with are jump to definition and find all
references
jump to definition is is a feature where
you could click on that blue name in
your editor locally or on a website like
github
and what it'll do is it will take you to
the definition that we think that that
name refers to
the inverse of that find all references
would allow you to click on the red name
the definition and find all of the
occurrences in your program where there
are names that refer back to that
function
now that's like pretty basic stuff
there's other things that you can do
with this information because really
what you're producing is an uh a record
of the entire call graph of your program
all of the different functions all of
the different classes the way that the
different pieces of your code interact
with each other and with your
dependencies
and you can think of a lot of other
interesting features that could build
upon that data set if you have it
available but just for today we're going
to talk about those two basic code
navigation
features just as a way of grounding our
discussion in something relatively
simple
so why is this hard i showed a pretty
simple example here where it was pretty
obvious what the reference refers back
to so i want to start walking through
some more complex examples where it's
not
well it'll be clear to us as humans but
it's not necessarily clear how to detect
that programmatically
so now the first more complex example um
if you have eagle eyes you might spot
the difference here this is very similar
to the first example the only thing that
we've changed is that that first
definition is now broil instead of bake
and what that means is that we now have
two definitions in this file with the
same name there's two functions that are
called braille
and what are we going to do in this in
this case
this actually depends specifically on
the fact that we're using python for
this example in python the rules are
that the later definition overwrites or
shadows the earlier definition and so if
you were to click on the reference at
the end you would want it to show the
second of the two not the first
if we switch languages though and we
look at this example in rust instead
it's exactly the same thing just sort of
transcribed into a different language
interestingly in rust this is a compile
error
if you try to take this program and
compile it rust will tell you that
you're not allowed to have multiple
definitions at the same scope with the
same name and we'll flag this as an
error so this is again highlighting the
fact that the rules that we have for
constructing this data
are going to depend on the particular
language that we're looking at it's not
something where we can create a single
universal set of rules that apply across
all of the languages that we're looking
at
we can also make this more complex by
breaking the content up into multiple
files because it's very very unlikely
that you're working on any real code
base that's isolated to a single file
right so here what we've done is we have
the reference in the file on the right
and we have the definition in the file
on the left and we should be able to
sort of trace through this import
statement to see that the reference
refers to the definition over in
stove.pi
and again this is building upon some
language specific intuition that we have
about how import statements are
structured and what particular names
they bring into scope from other files
we can take this a step further and
separate this into multiple packages or
repositories so here i've tried to use
these emojis here to
represent package names so we have down
in the lower right corner chef.pie
that's where the reference is it's in
this package which has the the sort of
chef emoji as its identifier the
definition is up in the package in the
upper left
we've introduced a third file here as
well along with a what i like to call a
re-export statement so if you're not
familiar with python with that middle
kitchen.pi file is doing is it's loading
in all of the symbols from stove.pi and
making them available under the kitchen
module as well
and so what that means is that we can
trace this path from the reference all
the way up to the definition we have to
go through a couple of import statements
we have to go through a number of files
but eventually we do landed the
definition like we were before
another way that this example is
interesting though is that you might
come along and change the content of
kitchen.pie
and this is sort of highlighting how
we're building code navigation
specifically for a hosted website like
github and not necessarily for a local
editor
what is interesting here is that now we
have two definitions of broil so you
might imagine that what happened is that
the package owners have discovered that
there's something weird going on with
the broil function and so they've
introduced some logging just so that
they can see when it's being invoked and
you might imagine more complex logging i
just used a print statement here to keep
the example simple
but what this does is it changes the
name binding the reference down in
chef.pie now lands on this new function
that was introduced in kitchen.pie
and this is important because it was not
the file that contains the reference
that changed and it was not the file
that contained the original definition
that changed it was this intermediate
file that we had to move through along
the way from the reference to the
definition that changed
and so that means that in the naive case
anytime any file
in your repository or in any of your
transit of dependencies changes
we might have to go through and
recalculate these results to see what
our references are landing on
okay one last complex example here we're
adding uh classes python classes and the
reason for that is that we want to show
that we still want to click on broil we
still want it to resolve up here into
the stove.pi on the left but now it's
not a function at the top file level
scope it's actually an instance method
inside of a class defined inside that
file so now over at the reference you
can see that we're not just calling
broil directly we're calling broil on
this stove local variable
and what that means is the path is much
more complex right as we start to figure
out what broil refers to we have to
pause
the the lookup of broil and start doing
a lookup of stove this local variable
because what it is what its content is
is going to affect what broil might
resolve to because you might have a
different thing that has members that
you need to go find what it is and then
be able to see what broil member is in
there so we have to pause our lookup of
broil start looking up lowercase stove
in this case we're lucky because it's
just defined as a local variable one
line up but that might not be the case
it might be defined anywhere
having seen that it's this local
variable we now have to see what its
value is
in this case the value is the result of
calling this capital s stove
so now we have to pause our lookup again
and go figure out what that is
like we were doing before we can move
through these multiple import statements
to go find the definition of capital s
stove in stove.pi
and we can see that it's a class so now
again we have to bring in our knowledge
of python to know that when you invoke a
class what you get is an instance a new
instance of that class it's like the new
operator in python
so now we can come back and see that
that's what the result of this call step
is
so that then we can go find the class
definition and see that there's an
instance member inside of it called
braille so we had to bounce back and
forth between multiple files multiple
times we had to pause our lookup a
couple of times in order to get
subsidiary results which our
original lookup depended on but we were
eventually able to sort of land on the
definition that we looked for that we
wanted to find
okay so uh
is that all right so i've sort of i've
sort of shown some interesting examples
where just the act of you know finding
the necessary results that we care about
can be complex is that all that we have
to care about
and as you might expect it's not um we
also have this sort of non-functional
requirement that we want this entire
thing to be zero config
we are wanting to turn on precise code
navigation as a feature for an entire
ecosystem we want to be able to say that
we now know how to extract this
information for python so we're just
going to turn it on for all public and
private python repositories it's not
something where we want individual
package owners to have to tell us how to
collect the necessary data or to
configure a ci job to produce that data
for us we want to be able to do that all
by ourselves sort of internally as an
internal service and have this just be a
feature that just works
we also have to deal with scale
github is a large website right there's
a lot of code hosted there
our most recent public numbers we have
200 million repositories and counting
that's public and private
we have two billion contribute
contributions over the past year
not all of those
are pushes or commits but a lot of them
are like a substantial fraction of those
are and so that just shows the volume
the fire hose of incoming changes that
we have to keep up with
and also interestingly for this
particular use case we have a lot of
programming languages that we need to
worry about right a lot of the examples
that i showed you i talked about how we
needed language specific rules to know
what data to extract and if you look at
linguist which is our open source
repository that has language specific
information in it
it currently tracks around 500
programming languages and a lot of those
are only in support of things like
language detection you can't do anything
more advanced with them but it's just
showing that there's this really long
tail of programming languages and we
want to in some way be able to support
all of them
so how are we going to do this um
for a hosted service what this means is
we kind of have two phases of execution
where we get to think about generating
this data in supportive user queries we
have index time which is when the code
is coming in when it's pushed right when
somebody pushes up a new change and then
we have query time which is when a user
is trying to navigate that code on the
website and it might be different people
who are doing those two operations right
the package owner or you know one of the
contributors will be doing the
event that triggers the in-text time
behavior but it's anyone at all who
might be coming along and viewing this
code and trying to explore it and and
figure out how it works
so we have to figure out how to
take this work that we have to do and
divide it up amongst index time and
query time in the most efficient way
and we have some constraints we can't do
too much work at query time because this
is an interactive feature that we're
trying to produce we want it to actually
be fast enough to generate the results
as users are clicking around on the code
view on github.com and what that means
is that we have a goal of you know
around 100 milliseconds for the maximum
amount of time that our query step can
take anything more than that and it
starts to affect the human perceived
latency and it becomes too slow for an
interactive feature
on the converse we can't do too much
work at index time because of all of
those scale concerns that i just told
you about we have so much data
being stored and coming in on an ongoing
basis that we have to make sure that we
are reusing work as much as we can we
can't be in a situation where we really
do have to re-index every single thing
in your repository and all of your
transitive dependencies every time
there's any minuscule change in any of
them that's just a non-starter both in
terms of the storage costs that would be
needed and the compute costs to
calculate that data
what we want to do is we want to find a
way to strike a balance we have to do
as much precalculation as we can at
index time and we want to minimize the
amount of duplicated work so that we can
reuse results as much as possible
and
in order to do that if we need to defer
some amount of work to query time that's
okay as long as we don't defer so much
work that we end up exceeding that 100
millisecond budget for queries
and incremental processing is sort of
how we how we do that
we're leaning into the fact that we're
calculating this data for git content
git's data model provides a very nice
friendly way of doing this kind of item
potent work if you will
when a typical commit comes in
it's very likely that that commit has
only changed a small number of the files
in your repository and all of the other
files in your repo have the same content
and live at the same locations that they
did before and so our goal is to reuse
results that we've already calculated
for any of those unchanged files
and in particular it's not just the
storage that we're trying to save so you
could imagine that you're going to go
through and actually spend the compute
to analyze everything and you'll see
that the results that you got for a
particular file aren't different than
what you had before so okay we don't
need to store a new copy of that data
it's already there but we're trying to
take it a step further and actually save
on the compute as well we want to be
able to see from the get data itself
that a file hasn't changed and know that
the results that we had already
calculated for that file are still valid
and can be reused without having to do
any work for those files at all at index
time
okay so to summarize we've spent a fair
bit of time now talking about why this
is a hard problem
we've talked about how there are
language specific rules that can be
quite complex that we have to take into
account while we generate this data
we've talked about how the results can
depend on intermediate files and so that
can
be viral if you're not careful in terms
of when and how you have to recalculate
things we've talked about how we want
this to be a zero config it just works
kind of feature
and then we've talked about how in
particular we need incremental
processing in order to do all of this at
scale
so how are we going to do this in a way
that satisfies all five of these
checkboxes
so i want to
start to
in a sort of conceptual way just sort of
in english let's look at this problem a
little bit deeper what would incremental
results for code navigation look like
so let's go back to one of our simple
examples this is the one where the
reference and the definition are in
separate files but we're not doing
anything else more complex
what we want to do again incremental
that means that we have to look at
individual files completely in isolation
and we can't look at any of the other
files in our repository or in any of our
dependencies so looking at individual
files what information can we
use to describe the content of the
source code
so looking first at stove.pi
we can look at this in isolation and say
that there is a symbol called
stove.broil defined at this particular
location we don't need any information
from other files to see that
similarly if we look at kitchen.pie we
can see that there is a reference on
line three and because of the import
statement we can see that that reference
refers to some symbol called
stove.braille and because it's in an
import statement we know that the
definition of that symbol is in some
other file
we don't know what file that is because
we can't look at any of the other files
in our repository or dependencies
but we know that it needs to exist and
there needs to be this symbol defined
somewhere in it for this reference to
land correctly somewhere
and what's nice is that we can actually
combine those two facts right you can
sort of use stove.broil if you will as a
join key or or or something like that
that allows you to merge together or
link together those two statements
um
and what you get if you combine the two
is the the sort of like derived fact at
the end which is that the reference at
kitchenpie 31
is defined at stovepi four five and so
this is showing how we've done some of
the work at index time that's where we
generated those facts looking only at
individual files and then at query time
we loaded in those facts and merged them
together to get our final code
navigation lookup results
okay so we can do this with the more
complex example as well we're going to
do the exact same process we're going to
look at files individually and see what
english language facts we can use to
describe them
so first for stove.pi there's actually
going to be two facts here that we care
about
the first is that you can invoke stove
dot stove
and we know that the name the fully
qualified name stove dot stove comes
both from the name of the class in the
class class definition
and also from the name of the file
because in python it's the file name
that determines the name of the module
in that file
if you invoke stove.stove what you get
is an instance of the stove class and we
know that part of the fact because of
our knowledge of python that classes are
things that you can evoke when you do so
you get an instance of the class
the other fact that we have in this file
is that the stove class has an instance
member named broil
which is defined at a particular
location and again this is just looking
at the definition of the class this is
what it means to define instance members
in python and so we can just sort of
like encode that
narratively in an english fact
kitchen.pi this is the one with the
re-import statement that we talked about
the fact that we're going to write about
this one is that if you are looking for
kitchen dot anything at all
you might instead find it at stove dot
that same thing and this is because the
import star in python does this
re-export semantics that we talked about
earlier
and then lastly this is the most complex
one in chef.pie
um
we can see and this is sort of encoding
some of the stuff that we walked through
manually as we traced the path a couple
of slides back
if you can find what kitchen.stove
resolves to and those two names are
coming from the content of the import
statement
and then you can call that once you find
out what stove is we're going to try to
call it
the result should have an instance
member or sorry i don't know that it's
an instance number yet because i don't
know that stove is a class because i'm
not looking at any other files
but i know that it has some kind of
member
named broil because otherwise that dot
syntax wouldn't work
um and that member is what this braille
reference at chef.pi47 resolves to
so this is a more complex fact it has
multiple clauses it's talking about that
fact that we have to pause our lookups
and look up other things and get the
results and then do some stuff with it
but we can still write this out in
english and understand what we're trying
to do
and then similarly we can do this
combination step at query time to turn
this into a real good navigation lookup
result so we have the long one if you
can find what kitchen.stove etc
and then we have the rename fact that we
talked about where if you're looking for
kitchen dot anything you can rename it
and start looking for stove got anything
so we're gonna go change that
kitchen.stove in the first fact
to stove.stove so we're updating our
fact as we go along with more
information that we're pulling in about
the files that we're looking at
the next fact that we're going to care
about is that if you invoke stove.stove
what you get back is an instance of the
stove class so again we can combine
those together substitute in and so now
what we have is the stove class needs to
have that member named broyle and if you
can find it that's what the reference
resolves to
and then our last fact is the one that
says well it does the stove class does
have an instance number and in
particular that instance number is this
definition
and so combining those two together you
get the final fact which is that
the definition at
stove.pi59 is what the reference
resolves to
so it was multiple steps to sort of
combine information it's not always just
going to be two things that combine
together but there still is this process
where we can generate these facts
incrementally looking at individual
files and at query time we can load in
the ones that we care about do this
merge step and eventually hopefully land
at a result
okay so let's start moving into
not just talking about this conceptually
with english facts how are we going to
actually do this programmatically with
with an actual process that a computer
could execute and now we're going to
start talking about stack graphs
okay so we're looking at our simple
example again we're going to look at
stove.pi first and what we're going to
do here is we're going to create a graph
structure and the goal of this graph is
to represent all of the interesting name
binding information that we can express
about this file
and you can see that there are nodes in
the graph that correspond with the
definitions in the file so i'm using
this
red double bordered
rectangle that's what we call a
definition node that's what each of the
definitions in the file will have
somewhere in the graph that we create
for that file
it might be hard to see but i've just
highlighted the sort of linked list of
five circular nodes in the middle there
that particular structure of nodes and
how they're linked together is what
encodes the fact that in python later
definitions in a file shadow earlier
ones
if we were creating the stack graph for
a language like rust we would actually
choose a different structure of nodes
and edges in order to encode the fact
that in rust all of the definitions are
sort of part of a single file level
scope and there isn't any shadowing
there and instead you have conflicting
definitions if you have the same names
and then lastly again as we mentioned in
python the name of the module is
determined by the name of the file
containing the content and so we have
these nodes here saying that all of
these definitions
their fully qualified name would include
this stove module name
now we're going to do the same thing for
kitchen.pie we're going to create a
graph for it as well
the references in a file also appear as
nodes in the graph in this case i'm
using blue and single borders to
indicate references
the import statement translates into
this gadget of nodes
and this particular shape is something
that we will always create for this kind
of import statement
and we'll see in the next slide how in
particular this actually implements the
semantics of a python import statement
what we can do with those two graphs is
we can merge them together right so i
showed the graphs that we created in
isolation we can load them in and create
sort of like a large graph which is just
the union of all of the nodes and edges
from the two
per file graphs that we created and the
only interesting wrinkle here is that
that filled in black node which is what
we call the root node is shared across
all of the files so as we pull in all of
the files their root nodes will get
merged together into a single node but
in all other ways the graph structure is
sort of performing these clicks
where there is a portion of the graph
which came from stove.pi and it is
completely isolated from the portion of
the graph that came from kitchen.pie
but in all other ways it's just a very
simple take the two subgraphs for the
two files and merge them together into a
single graph
and having done so
the name binding
the name binding that we had found
earlier is a path in this graph
so the fact that we can go from the
broil reference
through these other nodes over to the
broil definition is what represents the
fact that that is a valid name binding
lookup in this particular set of files
now it's not any path that works here
because if you notice like i could just
find create a path from broil to the
saute definition and that's not one of
the look-up results that you might
expect
so how are we going to rule that out
we're going to use this concept that we
call a symbol stack so as we walk
through the edges in the path we're
going to maintain the symbol stack which
is representing the thing that we're
currently looking for in order to finish
this name binding lookup
so we start at the broil reference and
the thing that we're looking for is that
symbol braille so in general blue nodes
are going to push things on to this
symbol stack
and now we can start to move through the
edges in the graph when we get to a red
node we're going to try to pop something
off the top of the symbol stack and what
that means is that the
symbol at the top of the stack has to
match the content of the node otherwise
this isn't going to succeed
so we can go through this broil node
because it does match and we can keep
going blue nodes are going to push
things on and so what this gadget has
done is it's rewritten the lookup of
unqualified stove into a qualified
lookup of i'm sorry unqualified lookup
of broil into a qualified lookup of
stove.broil because that's what an
import statement does is it says go find
it in this module
the other thing that an import statement
does is it tells you to go look for that
qualified reference in a different file
and so the other thing that the import
gadget does is it takes you to the root
node because the root node is how you
cross from one file to another
so now here we couldn't go right into
the kitchen node because again the top
of the stack has to match and top of
stack is not kitchen so we can't go that
way we can only go left
and so we pop off the stove dot this is
the definition of the module that we
just walked into and then we can proceed
up until we get to the broil definition
which pops the last element off the
stack and that leaves us with the
binding path which is valid and we
weren't able to go into saute or into
bake again because that doesn't match
top of stack
okay let's do this for the more complex
example
we're going to skip the step where we
look at the stack graphs for each file
in isolation and we're just going to
show the combined graph as a whole but
again just like before there's a portion
of the graph for each
of the three files and they're distinct
from each other the only place where
they come together is that shared root
node in the middle
and in this graph it's still the case
that there's a path from the broil
reference to the royal definition it's a
much longer and more complex path
because this is a more complex example
but the mechanics of what we did are
going to be exactly the same
so we start at the reference we push
broil onto the stack we actually push a
couple of more things on because it's an
instance member that we're looking for
this time so what we're actually trying
to find is lowercase stove.broil
and now if you remember the next thing
that we have to do is figure out what
stove refers to and so because this is a
stack
that sort of pause the later bits in
order to do some earlier bits comes for
free that's just what stacks do
so we keep walking through the graph and
we're able to find luckily just one line
above that there's a definition of stove
as a local variable
and we have attached to its definition
nodes that describe what its value is so
if we move through those we see that
lowercase stove the local variable is
the result of calling capital s stove
and again we don't know what capital
stove is yet but we have at least pushed
under the single stack that we need to
go find that out so that we can continue
our lookup
we keep going up further in the file we
have the same import statement gadget
that we had before which says that ah
you're looking for capital s stove you
probably need to go find that in the
kitchen module
and because it's an import statement go
look for it in another file so let's go
to the root node
now we can go up into kitchen.pie move
through these nodes which have the
effect of replacing the lookup of
kitchen.stove with a lookup of
stove.stove and again it comes back down
to the into the root note again because
we have to go look for stove.stove in
some other file
we can move down into stove.pi pop off
the definition of the stove module now
we're into the nodes that we created for
the class definition itself and so we
pop off the name of the class which is
good it matches what we're looking for
we've added this call
node here because you are allowed to
invoke classes in python and what you
get as a result this im label is meant
to stand for instance members this is
the scope that we created that holds all
of the instance members of that class
and so if you invoke the class you get
an instance of the class
and inside of that you can pop off your
member access operator and go find the
particular instance member that you're
looking for
so it was still just a path it went
through a number of files we pushed and
popped a whole lot of stuff to make it
work but mechanically it's the same
thing that we did in the simpler example
okay good we're done right
we did it
i'm to hopefully say that no we didn't
we're still doing too much work at query
time
what i described works and it is
incremental in that the graphs that we
create for each file
depend only on the content of those
files and so we can reuse the graphs
that we create if the file doesn't
change
but at query time we're doing a pretty
expensive computation we're loading all
of those sub graphs joining them
together and then doing this fairly
expensive pathfinding operation in order
to find the the name binding lookups
that we care about and that works it
just has
shifted too much of the work to query
time and so now we're going to violate
that 100 millisecond budget that we
talked about
so we want to shift more of the work to
index time while still sort of having
that same basic incremental shape that
we talked about
and what we're going to use for that is
this thing called partial paths
so now we're looking again at the stack
graph that we created for one of these
files in isolation what we're going to
do is we're going to do that pathfinding
algorithm that before we did on the
combined graph but we're only going to
do it just looking at the graph for this
individual file
and it means we're not going to find a
complete name binding result but we're
going to see how much of the result that
we can calculate without having to move
elsewhere
so in this case we have this sub path
that goes from the broil reference to
the root node and we can describe that
as what we call a partial path
it has a start node and an end node in
this case the start node is that broil
reference the end node is the root node
and we also have what we call the
precondition and post condition the
precondition describes what has to be
true of the symbol stack for us to be
allowed
to use this partial path
right
and we'll see an example of the
precondition on the next slide
the postcondition tells us if we are
allowed to use this partial path what
effect does it have on the symbol stack
that we're building up
in this case there is no precondition
you can start at that reference whenever
you want
but if we were to use this partial path
right it goes through a couple of push
and pop nodes the final result that it
has on the symbol stack is that we will
have pushed stove.broil onto it and
that's encoded in the post condition
um and what's really nice is that this
is a sort of like uh rigorous or you
know like data encoding of that english
language fact that we talked about
before so the reference that's the blue
node
refers to stove.broil the
stove.royalpart is encoded in the
postcondition
in some other file that's encoded in the
fact that the end node is the root node
because that's how you move from one
file to another so this partial path is
an encoding of that english language
fact that we talked about before
we can do the same thing in stove.pi we
have a path that goes from the root node
to the definition
and so we have you know us the start
node is root the endnote is that
definition node now we have a
precondition we're not allowed to go
through those red nodes because they pop
things off the stack unless the stack
contains the corresponding symbols
otherwise each of those pop nodes will
be invalid and we can't use it so
there's a precondition that says the top
of the stack needs to be stove.broil
otherwise we aren't legally allowed to
go through those nodes and use this
partial path if we do use this partial
path we have we will have popped that
content off and so what's left in its
place is nothing empty empty symbol
stack
and this corresponds with the fact that
there is a definition called stove.royal
at a particular location
and like before we did this combination
step on the english language facts
in the partial path world that's an
operation that we call concatenation you
can concatenate two partial paths and it
produces a new partial path for that to
be valid
the end node of the left-hand side must
match the start node of the right-hand
side right because otherwise they
wouldn't be able to join together
and the post-condition of the left and
the precondition of the right have to be
compatible with each other
and if they are
you can concatenate these two partial
paths together and this partial path
which starts a reference and ends at a
definition is a complete partial path
it's a silly name but that's what we
call it
which represents that overall name
binding result it starts at the
reference it ends up the definition it
tells you a valid mapping from one to
the other
okay let's do it with more complex
example
again we're going to look for partial
paths
in this case we have one that starts at
the root node and goes to the instance
member node uh it has these pop nodes as
well so we have a precondition
this corresponds with the fact that
invoking stove.stove gives you an
instance of the stove class
there's another path in this file
partial path in this file that starts at
the instance member node and goes to the
broil definition
it has a precondition because there's
pop nodes this corresponds with the fact
that the stove class has an instance
member named broil
we're going to do the same thing for
kitchen.pie this only has one path
it starts at the root node and ends at
the root node and it has both a
precondition and a post condition
and it encodes the fact that if you're
looking for kitchen dot anything you
might find it at stove dot anything
and then in shaft up high this will be
the doozy
there is a relatively long partial path
from the broil reference to the root
node
and we've pushed quite a lot of stuff
onto the stack in order to get there but
if you just sort of read that off it's
actually going to line up very clearly
with the english fact that we talked
about before that if you can find what
kitchen.stove resolves to and you can
call it the result should have a member
name broil and that's what the reference
refers to
and again we can do this combination
operator by concatenating partial paths
um so we start off with the big one that
starts at the reference and we use our
our re uh rewrite rule to change
kitchen.stove into stove.stove just like
we did before
we load in the partial path that says
that invoking the class gives you an
instance of that class and you know
those are compatible so we can merge
them together
then we load in the fact the partial
path that says that the class has an
instance member at this particular
location those are compatible and we can
merge them together and we get the final
complete path that tells us the result
okay are we done
um
we had this sort of list of five things
that we were trying to accomplish uh i
would contend that we've solved these
two pretty well the bit where you know
the result might depend on intermediate
files we need incremental processing i
think we have a good answer to that
right the
graphs that we create
depend only on the content of individual
files we have this partial path
mechanism partial path mechanism that
lets us pre-calculate a fair bit of work
at index time and then just join them
together i think we have a pretty good
answer to this
different languages have different name
binding rules some of those rules can be
quite complex a pretty good answer there
as well because we can create whatever
graph structure we need to
to implement the semantics of the
language that we're talking about so
that that one i think we've done pretty
well on we'll sort of get into
whether or not that's true in a second
or two
we haven't really talked at all about
the zero config part because we haven't
talked about how we create these stack
graphs at all i've just sort of waved my
hands and said oh you can create a graph
for this python file how are we actually
going to do that
for that we're going to leverage tree
sitter
which if you're not familiar with tree
sitter this is a project which lets you
implement parsers for programming
languages
it's a parser generator framework that
github originally created for use in the
atom text editor we also use it for a
number of other product features on
github and it's developing a pretty
thriving ecosystem there's a lot of
people starting to use tree sitter
outside of github as well you might have
noticed for instance that neovem
recently in their zero five release
incorporated native support for tree
sitter syntax highlighting as well so
this is
a language ecosystem that's that's
starting to get more traction outside of
github
and what tree sitter lets you do is you
provide a grammar for your programming
language and it allows you to parse the
raw source code into a syntax tree
and so this is the tree sitter syntax
tree for that file that we just saw
the other thing that tree sitter gives
you is this nice query syntax which lets
you look for patterns of nodes in that
parsed tree content
and so this is a query that would let
you look for any function definition
anywhere in the file
and this app notation is what we call a
capture which lets you attach a label to
some of the nodes that are coming out in
each of the matches
and in particular we have this name
capture here which is attaching to the
identifier inside of the function
definition that we just found and so
this query lets us extract out the name
of every function that's defined
anywhere in the file
this already exists treesetter has
the
sort of grammar dsl for defining the
grammars the generation step that builds
the parser from that this query language
that lets you look for patterns in the
trees that all exists that's an existing
part of the tree center ecosystem
what we've added is this new graph
construction dsl
which lets you attach to the tree center
queries
these statements that let you produce
arbitrary graphs that depend on the
content of the parsed syntax tree that
comes out of tree center and so this
snippet here you know creates a new node
attaches a couple of attributes to that
node and uses an edge to link that new
node with a node that we created
somewhere else in this graph dsl file
and that corresponds with this you know
sort of like gadget of nodes that we
might have created when i was showing
you all of the stack graph instances
earlier in the talk
so the idea is that for a particular
language that you want to support you
write a graph dsl file for that language
that defines the rules for which
particular gadgets of nodes and edges to
create for all of the different kinds of
language constructs that might come out
of the parser
and what's important to call out there
is that that means that we have a single
implementation of the stack graph
algorithms that i described
tree sitter itself is a single
implementation of that parser generator
step and teresa graph this new graph dsl
that we're creating is a single
implementation of that graph dsl the
only part that's different for each of
the languages is that there are language
specific repositories that hold the
grammar for python and the syntax
highlighting rules for python and the
fuzzy code navigation rules for python
and now we hope eventually the stack
graph rules for python
and you'll see that some of these tree
sitter repos are in the tree sitter org
because those are ones that my team sort
of developed ourselves in order to
bootstrap this process but you can also
see that quite a lot of languages are
starting to buy into this tree sitter
ecosystem and create their own
repositories for their own languages and
so this is how we try this is how we
claim that we can support that long tail
of languages that i talked about earlier
where we want to make sure that adding
statcraft support for your language does
not require a complex programming step
it does not require tapping into a
long-running and possibly expensive
build process it's hopefully something
that you can just create these
declarative graph construction rules in
order to generate the necessary stack
graph content for your for your
programming
language um and so i contend that that
means that we have found the right
balance between index time and query
time so at index time a new push comes
in we clone the files that have been
changed we parse them using the tree
sitter parser for that language we
construct the stack graph for that
parsed content using the stack graph
rules for that language
at that point we are now done with all
of the language specific parts we have a
stat graph we can run our partial
pathfinding algorithm to get a list of
the partial paths for that file and we
can stash them in a way stash them away
in a database
then at query time we can see the
reference that the user is clicking on
and load in from that database the
partial paths that we might need to
satisfy that lookup and stitch them
together using that combination that
concatenation operation that i showed
you
and it is fast we're finding that like
this there's a prototype of this
deployed internally that we have staff
shift for python
we're hoping to get that released in the
coming month or two
as a ga release we'll see
but it's fast like we're finding that
index times our median is five seconds
right so you push the content before you
have a chance to alt tab over to your
browser we have indexed that and stored
the partial paths in the database for
later querying
and the stitching algorithm is fast
enough that we're meeting those 100
millisecond budgets that we talked about
earlier our median times are 50
milliseconds our p99s are right around
uh right around 100. so it's working
um i just want to leave you with a
couple of even harder examples i i sort
of
this was a lot of dense content and we
actually have only scratched the surface
of what stack graphs can do so i want to
show a couple of really really hard
examples here so the one on the left is
sort of like our canonical example of
where sometimes lookup results depend on
data flow so if you look at what's
happening pass-through is a function
that takes in a parameter and then
immediately returns that as a new value
and so the
we want to be able to click on one the
reference at the bottom and have it go
to one the definition inside of the
class but in order for that to work we
have to trace the fact that you passed
in a particular parameter and got that
back as a result and so different
invocations of pass-through will have
different results depending on what
parameters you pass in
and then the example on the right uh is
an even more complex one which is
showing how in java you have generic
classes
and what we want in this example is that
if you were to click on length at the
end you should be able to see that first
off we have some inheritance going on so
we need to go find the very first method
entry set in our superclass
but we also need to see that it's not
just the generic hashmap that we've
inherited from we've inherited from a
particular instantiation of hashmap with
string and string as the key and value
types and so when we go through this
chain of methods we need to propagate
that information correctly so that when
we get to the end we know that it has to
be string.length in particular that
you're calling
and the stack framework works for both
of these examples it makes the
uh
formalism a little bit more complex we
actually have this thing called a scope
stack next to the symbol stack as well
which i didn't talk about at all
but it also makes the gadgets that you
create a little bit more complex but
it's still the same overall process
where it's a declarative language for
constructing the graphs and then this
nicely incremental division of work
between index time and query time
and with that that's everything so i
have credits for some of the pictures
that i included
and also like if you have if you're
interested in learning more about this
definitely come check us out in our open
source repositories so thanks very much
[Music]
you